amid the brutal destruction of
borodianca the Poise and Grace of a tiny
gymnast
on a canvas of rubble the art world's
most famously elusive figure Banksy has
left his mark
the Banksy has come to a place like
borodianca isn't a great surprise in the
context of some of his previous work but
it is of course a big surprise to the
people who live here the stenciled
artwork first appeared about a week ago
but not until it was posted on banksy's
own Instagram account could anyone be
certain it was his he just posted his
and the signature
at the bottom says like burjanka Ukraine
you're talking about balance a gymnast
balancing yeah this is somehow a metal
balancing and people who lives here also
balance in between daily routine and
like flashbacks from days when Russians
were here Alexi was a graffiti artist
too once 12 years ago he created this to
celebrate World Youth Day in his now
shattered Hometown the the tagline that
you could see at the top right corner
like the black one it says like all the
best for the children's
and I think it's kind of
it has some kind of symbolism we could
see the two different worlds like this
world on this picture like all the best
for the children and the another picture
of like Russian aggression and what they
can bring to to the world
svetlana's home was another in the
random line of Russian fire it was built
she tells me in 1914 surviving two world
wars but it's unlikely to recover from
this
it is a minor consolation that she now
lives across the street from a Banksy
original
if not for what happened here he might
not even know that bored Yanka exists
and it's really pleasing today to see
people smiling and taking pictures art
is an aesthetic pleasure it heals our
souls so this is very cool other works
have appeared not yet officially claimed
by Banksy here a child challenges a
putin-like figure at Judo here an
anti-tank defense enables children at
play and above a hole ripped by a tank
show the delicacy of a rhythmic gymnast
they seem to stand as tributes to life
in the ruins of War Jonah Al Jazeera
borodianca